here's one of the ways Amazon
manipulates people to buy more things
Amazon weaves in reviews and different
types of reviews all along their site
because they know it boosts sales
everybody seems to use them and the
reason they do that is because people
will do things that they've seen other
people do first is just by having it
visually displayed number one so people
can see it the second is trying to find
examples that are just like the Avatar
so if you have certain types of
customers you want other customers just
like them to show their experience and
the third way that you can make it more
powerful is that you show other people
who are just like them who are going
through the same circumstance or
experience and so if you can show all
three of those things it's actually even
more powerful than a really amazing
testimonial from someone in a different
circumstance or a different Walk of Life
and so if you put those three things
together you'll get way more conversions
on your websites your sales advertising
and everything you do to promote your
products and service